[Music]
trip hey Sam you'll see something crazy
let's sweep them out right now so do you
never seen anything like this Oh
residents have reported numerous
sightings with an unidentified creature
we're looking for something unusual
something dangerous
are you there's something going on here
I don't even know how to begin to
explain take a look you like siding in
my truck
this thing is awesome it's smart it's an
engine for my truck in that right Creech
noonim Creech
think you can keep up with me
you see that show aren't you curious
about where it came from
I'm gonna get you home and away from
whoever's after you I love you too let
go I can see better than you you're back
in their juices I trip this man might I
have a word we did not going anywhere
with you yes what Oh
the lobster is in the truck
oh did you see MIT that just happened oh
yeah it did
I'm scientists I want to help you you're
a family what do you the trucks
hope you pick something up from watching
me a week ago you were riding a bicycle
oh I really hope they have two seatbelts
on let go
okay crease let's get you fed I like
your truck Thanks
for reflexes I should have known better
than to sneak up on you like that were
you looking at the old family pictures
again no I wasn't sir I've seen you go
through similar face